[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter
theory in this video we're going to be
discussing
lord voldemort and his signature spell
the killing curse
avada kadavra more specifically we're
going to be discussing
the colour of his signature spell and
exploring why it is paired
with such sinister looking hues of green
ever since i first read the books i took
notice of the different colours that
spells produced
but never really thought much of it we
know that expelliarmus
is red patronuses are white and that
avada kedavra
is green and that's because it's
repeated over and over
however it recently occurred to me that
there must be some rationale
behind the iconic colours used in the
books the frequent clash of red and
green
between voldemort and harry must be
symbolic
in some way what do these jets of light
mean
before we delve into this further let's
take a brief look at the backstory
of avada kadavra the first thing that
you need to know about avada kadavra
is that it is perhaps the most sinister
of the unforgivable curses
three of the most dark and powerful
spells known to the wizarding world
the unforgivable curses are tools of the
dark arts
and generally only used by the darkest
and most sadistic witches and wizards
a category that voldemort fits into
perfectly avada kadavra
also known as the killing curse serves a
simple purpose
it puts an end to the victim's life if
you want to kill your victim
then this is the spell to use and it's
known to produce a blindingly intense
green bolt of light right before the
victim simply drops dead
the biological reason for how the victim
dies is not clear
but there are two existing theories the
first claiming that the victim's
internal organs
ceased to function after being struck
and the second
claiming that the soul of the victim is
magically ripped from their body
there was a flash of blinding green
light and a rushing sound
as though a vast invisible something was
soaring through the air
instantaneously the spider rolled over
onto its back
unmarked but unmistakably dead there it
is again
green light and there seems to be a
common theme between the color green
and spells that are generally considered
to be evil
we also see this with more mort
then he realized it was a colossal skull
comprised of what looked like emerald
stars
with the serpent protruding from its
mouth like a tongue
as they watched rose higher and higher
blazing
in a haze of greenish smoke etched
against the black sky
like a new constellation with that being
said
it would be all too easy to just make
the assumption that green
equals evil and because avada kadavra is
an evil spell
that it would assume the color green
however
i think that there's more to it than
that fortunately
this topic is somewhat touched on by jk
rowling
green has long had a supernatural
connection in the uk
superstition says that it ought to be
worn with care
the fairies are supposedly possessive of
it as it is their proper colour
it ought never to be worn at weddings
due to a further association
with misfortune and death green is the
color of much
dark magic of the dark mark of the
luminescent potion in which voldemort
conceals one of his horcruxes
of many dark spells and curses and of
slytherin house
for these reasons green seems like it
would have been an obvious choice for
rowling
when choosing a colour to assign to the
spell that represents death
and as for misfortune i can't think of
anything less fortuitous
than dying assigning the color green to
avada kadavra and other spells like it
allowed rolling to create a sort of
dichotomy of internal colour symbolism
these two conflicting worlds were
chiefly represented by voldemort's green
avada cadaver and harry's red expeliamus
very much unlike green red has an almost
unspoken
but seemingly implicit element of warmth
comfort
and security and so it seems fitting
that harry's go-to spell
expelliarmus would exude these almost
contrasting
characteristics one thing that i think
is worth mentioning
however is that green is a very diverse
color and can actually come across
in many different ways according to the
respective hue
avada kadavra at least in the films
sometimes looks almost
turquoise which to me doesn't exude the
same feelings of
death and misfortune commonly associated
with a darker more sinister looking
green
while darker hues of green commonly
represent things like death
greed ambition and wealth yellowy greens
are more representative of things like
jealousy sickness and cowardice and just
to make things
extra confusing olive green is a color
traditionally considered to represent
peace an association driven from the
symbol of the olive branch
in egyptian mythology colours are a
tricky part of storytelling because
often there is so much underlying
symbolism to be uncovered
for this reason authors should always be
careful not to arbitrarily choose
colours
as so much meaning whether intentional
or unintentional
can be derived from them in short green
was chosen for vada kadavra
because of its associations with death
and red was chosen
for expelliarmus because of its
contrasting nature with the green
of avada kedavra however these colour
decisions
only work for some aspects of the story
for example harry potter the hero
himself
has green eyes while the horrifying
unforgivable curse known as crucio
is red harry certainly isn't evil nor
does he represent death
and crucio is anything but warm these
two colour choices
directly contradict the duality of harry
potter's suggested
colour symbolism and that's why when it
comes to colours
things just aren't so black and white
and that's it for this video
if you enjoyed it please like and
subscribe to support the channel
until next time it does not do to dwell
on dreams
and forgets to live
you